we have four triangles depicted here and
they've told us that the triangles are
not drawn to scale and we are asked
which two triangles must be congruent so
pause this video and see if you can work
this out on your own before we work
through this together
all right now let's work through this
together and it looks like for every one
of these or actually almost every one of
these they've given us two angles and
they've given us a side this triangle i
j h they've only given us two angles
so what i'd like to do is if i know two
angles of a triangle i can figure out
the third angle because the sum of the
angles of a triangle have to add up to
180 degrees and then i can use that
information maybe with the size that
they give us in order to judge which of
these triangles are congruent
so first of all what is going to be the
measure of this angle right over here
the measure of angle a c b pause the
video and try to think about that
well one way to think about it if we
call the measure of that angle x
we know that x plus 36 plus 82 needs to
be equal to 180. i'm just giving their
measures in degrees here and so you
could say x plus let's see 36 plus 82 is
a hundred and eighteen did i do that
right six plus two is eight and then
three plus eight is eleven yep that's
right so that's going to be equal to 180
and then if i subtract 118 from both
sides i am going to get x is equal to
180 minus 18 is 62.
so this is x is equal to 62 or this is a
62 degree angle i guess is another way
of thinking about it i could put
everything in terms of
degrees
if you like all right now let's do the
same thing with this one right over here
well this one has an 82 degree angle and
a 62 degree angle just like this
triangle over here so we know that the
third angle needs to be 36 degrees
36 degrees because we know 82 and 62 if
you need to get to 180 it has to be 36.
we just figured that out from this first
triangle over here
now if we look over here 36 degrees and
59 this definitely looks like it has
different angles but let's figure out
what this angle would have to be so if
we call that
y degrees we know i'll do it over here y
plus 36 plus 59 is equal to 180 and i'm
just thinking in terms of degrees here
so y plus
this is going to be equal to what is
this this is going to be equal to 95
is equal to 180 did i do that right yep
that's 80 plus 15 you have 95 and then
if i subtract 95 from both sides
what am i left with i'm left with y is
equal to
85
degrees
and so this is going to be equal to 85
degrees
and then this last triangle right over
here i have an angle that has measure 36
another one that's 59 so by the same
logic this one over here has to be 85
degrees so let's ask ourselves now that
we've figured out a little bit more
about these triangles which of these two
must be congruent
so you might be tempted to look at these
bottom two triangles and say hey look
all of their angles are the same you
have angle angle angle and angle angle
angle
well they would be similar if you have
three angles at this that are the same
you definitely have similar triangles
but we don't have any length information
for triangle i j h you need to know at
least one of the lengths of one of the
sides in order to even think start to
think about congruence and so we can't
make any conclusion that i j h and l
m k triangles i j h and triangles l m k
are congruent to each other
now let's look at these candidates up
here we know that their angles are all
the same and so we could apply we could
apply angle just a different color angle
side
angle 36 degrees length 6 82 degrees
36 degrees
length 6
82 degrees so by
angle side angle
we know that triangle
a
b c
is indeed congruent to triangle f
d
e